[Music]
very exciting especially for our lady at
the factory running and karl marx
teachers who was very put on the spot
when i was talking about that quite cool
so the bolshevik revolution um let's go
to suggestion number two usually i like
trying to do something like banter and
stuff with you but you have the voice of
someone who did a dissertation on it
postgraduate studies about the bolshevik
reference
teletubby with the coat hanger ariel and
the little red handbag
so far guys
i feel like you both teach post-graduate
studies and
that definitely is a dissertation
[Music]
[ __ ]
i might not even wrap this crowd work is
really fun this is good
portrait revolution tinker in his career
icon middle of the room hey making
suggestion not middle of the road what's
it going to be
[Music]
do you want to have sex and they go sure
that is not that is not firm
enthusiastic consent
can we raise our sons here
no so the quiet so it's clearly not what
i said so what what do you mean the
concept of a choir
oh it's an a choir sorry i'm mixed in my
articles okay a quieter are you yourself
in a choir yes yes what the position do
you sing
uh
you conduct [ __ ]
that's pretty [ __ ] boring
the most christian thing ever just like
how do we connect with
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you just mean dogs that are fat you're
not referencing the community episodes
where they have to
people here not what i would figure that
my demographic would watch community and
therefore be aware of the episode where
senior chang
like
has to disguise the fact that
somebody if someone's like eaten by a
bear this is so complicated but they do
a dance called the fat dog
it's not made up it's not good there's
no water in it
it's bringing such a [ __ ] good show
all right
that does great
i won't mention community in the rap
whatever
uh and then i guess this section here
now the final section so far just you
know what we've got we've got the
bolshevik revolution tiki minky's the
queer ice on the fire fat dogs and i
love the matter of fact where you said
it it was just lovely
so this this suggestion over here what's
it gonna be
[Music]
oh yeah okay so i mean the fact that no
one here watches community makes me
think that no one here actually knows
who the [ __ ] i am because i just attract
internet nerds and losers and
essentially my dad puts wraps up on
youtube um about me which is real nice
and
they're quite good actually the best
line he ever did was uh chris turner is
the greatest freestyle rapper that makes
me the freestyle packer
okay
supportive dance who freestyle rap
sick i'm excited about these suggestions
actually and i would not lie if i wasn't
i would tell you so they were good
it
[Music]
okay
i like to have a life as a four-year-old
in the past i would spy on the green
grass oh four wrote some friends that's
the teletubbies like again and again and
the baby
[Music]
[Music]
he's got a little gucci one that he's
found disappears that's kind of weird
stick in the head usually it's just a
little flat one but it's red he's a nice
one gay icon for sure the red on the
zombie a flag that they adore but you've
got to move back before you pick [ __ ]
all of the emperor of the bolsheviks
they're coming yeah they've got the
swords and the malice they're gonna
invade that winter palace kill another
czar kill him of his family we need to
free the proletariat we need to set him
free and out of the ashes of the
revolution karl marx had that solution
saying we need to rise up so
now we're going to be the empire so
is it okay for me to put the words in
your brain right now with the war in
your brain i don't know but you're
praying your neck you're like okay i'll
be going to check one thing that i
admire the singing in the choir the bass
going low and sopranos going higher like
[Music]
what a fun way
to celebrate our love for jesus christ
you might not be secular it's my advice
you can gather round let's go i want the
baritone and the nexo and the alto 2 but
you're the conductor wouldn't be in time
it would be [ __ ] for sure if you were
there moving them on just wackling
around like your user but on like start
singing bring up the noise you over here
tiny little boys we like to cut your
balls off then it's a party you'll feel
hearty sing highly pastrati they used to
do that in italy but i'm sure you don't
do it in edinburgh or scotland anymore
like off your balls go hit the high
notes but still it sounds so nice you
get my hope and over here i'm feeling so
mad i see god jesus is supportive and if
jesus was there on the cross god is like
i'm sad for my loss but don't worry i'll
pull the nails right back bring you back
watch this do a nice god wrap oh
yes the best of the rappers over there
to your left it's barabbas
i've got so many bars on offer it's this
blast for me it's really kind of
frightening genuinely worried about my
lighting i'm just saying that you're the
[ __ ] real rap god i don't believe in
him but i think it does the job anyway
rap god like a fat dog i like that
you've got the own right there and your
god i'm right there on the street having
such fun see your corgi i adore these i
need to run i'm getting all the pound
dots i'll be telling these go and chase
a [ __ ] bone losing [ __ ] calories
[Applause]